[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka your uncle kevin
spoilers and it seems like hawkeye could
be bringing a big character into the mcu
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking down all the theories
surrounding who ekko's uncle is and the
evidence to support who the
quote-unquote family member could be did
someone say family
get the hell out of here a full
spoiler's ahead so if you aren't caught
up to the show then it's time to show
yourself the door if you enjoy the video
then please click the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
on the series every week without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our theories of who the uncle
is on hawkeye
okay so episode 3 opens in 2007 and much
like how we got a flashback of kate's
past here we learn about ekkos we
discover not only her incredible mimic
abilities but also her father's
connection to the tracksuit mafia in the
comics he was a character called crazy
horse who worked as an assassin but here
he's very much a new york gangster who's
high up in the organization whereas in
the source material her father was
killed when she was very young in the
mcu he lived for much longer and even
survived the snap however it was during
this time that he ran into the ronin who
killed him along with a number of gang
members as we learn in episode 3 there's
very much someone overseeing the actions
of the mafia and though we don't
discover who this is he's introduced his
echoes on call very early on now the
first theory i want to dive into comes
from balance bringer who left it on our
episode 3 breakdown balance bringer not
only sounds like thanos best mate but
they also said that the uncle could be
kate's father now before you roll your
eyes yes shut the hell up and listen as
i actually think it's quite a big
possibility in the comics kate's mother
apparently died when she was very young
and she was raised by her dad however it
was revealed years later that she was in
fact alive and in league with madame
mask and also the kingpin they've
clearly changed things up in the show so
that it's kate's mother eleanor who
lived whereas it was her dad that
apparently died however we never saw a
body and he may pop up down the line
much like how she did in the comics now
other things to add to this are that we
know kate's father was well off in their
argument ellen brought up that he was so
used to having things easy that he
assumed a solution to their debt was
gonna fall out of the sky whilst that
was the case yeah he clearly comes from
a powerful background and if he's so
used to having things his way it might
be because his family have ruled over
the city they also got to keep the
penthouse in the end and though this
might be because of insurance reasons
it's clear that the bishops have some
pull being the owners of a security
business would also allow them to have a
lot of access to the city so kate's dad
being the uncle could be a possibility i
actually think that it would be a much
bigger twist than it being some of the
other suspects but there are some things
that don't make it seem likely either
kate's father clearly loved her and i
don't think that he would abandon his
daughter and fake his own death just to
keep a hold of a house that he could
probably sell plus i'm not too sure how
happy he would be about eleanor hooking
up with jack and i think the reveal in
the show will probably be that elena
killed him during the battle of new york
and then she kept the penthouse because
of this now the most obvious candidate
is the kingpin ever since the netflix
shows were cancelled three years ago
there's been a lot of hoping and praying
that he'll come back according to behind
the scenes reports kevin feige actually
had no plans to bring the netflix
characters across but after hashtag save
daredevil trended on twitter he then
changed his mind vincent and ofrio
hasn't confirmed he's coming back either
but he has been talking about the show
on twitter and saying how fun it looks
vincent this is something that you
didn't do for what if and i'm gonna need
to know why also whilst you're at it
show me your thumbs your punk i said
show em now the kingpin is the most
likely character for me to arrive and if
we look at the comics it's also the most
in line with them in the comics kingpin
killed echo's father and in his dying
breath he asked fisk to take care of his
daughter this is a promise he fulfilled
and he enrolled meyer into all the best
schools and raised her like she was his
own fisk of course kept it from her that
he killed her dad and he ended up using
her as one of his best assassins kingpin
sent echo after matt murdock and she
posed as a love interest before
revealing the true plan however she
discovered that it was kingpin who was
responsible for her father's death and
then became a good guy we know ekko has
a disney plus show coming down the line
i think it would be great to see her
discovering kingpin tipped off the ronin
and this could lead into her hunting
down fisk now other hints towards it
being the kingpin is that in the comics
both the tracksuit mafia and kazi work
for him the building we saw in the first
episode is also where fisk resided in
the netflix series to top this off the
character also had a black suit like
what we saw and though i haven't been
able to verify this youtube user adam
said on my last video that they were
from germany and that marvel had used
the same voice actor for the kingpin as
they had with the netflix shows i think
wilson fisk is the most likely candidate
when we look at everything and though
maya regarded him as a father figure in
the comics and uncle is somewhat that
too he clearly had a close relationship
with her and though a real dad lived
longer than he did in the source
material because they were friends maya
probably spent a lot of time with him
when we occurred to her as an adult
she's also visiting fat man or a repair
which was a nickname that kingpin had in
the comics now there's been a lot of
videos on the characters cufflinks
especially as kingpin used to take great
pride in his i have looked at these a
lot and they don't really line up with
the ones that he typically wore but i
know a lot of people are going down the
rabbit hole on that however i actually
started re-watching the daredevil
netflix show last night and one thing
that they make a big point in that is is
that no one says fisk's name the
character achieves complete anonymity
because people refuse to say who he is
and uncle could be used in a similar
manner plus there's that laugh
so looking at it from a top level view
we have the actor behind kingpin saying
the show looks fun landmarks from the
netflix series popping up ties to the
comic characters and their origin
stories the potential reuse of a voice
actor and just the general feeling
behind the whole series i think getting
kingpin back would be massive and if
rumors about matt murdock being in no
way home are true then potentially on
the 15th we could see kingpin and
hawkeye on the morning and then mati on
the evening in spider-man
what's up mate no way home doesn't
release until the 16th and 17th for you
haha you sucker you should have moved to
the uk we get it on the 50th you sucker
anyway i really hope that's him and if
they ralph boner us again then i'm gonna
become the joker now there's also the
possibility that it could be jack which
i've seen pop up a couple of times
there's definitely a chance but i am
still holding out hope that jack will be
a good guy add to this clint hinted that
he knew who was running the show and
that they were above echo if he was well
aware of the person in charge then he
would be aware of jack and as they go to
kate's without that ever coming up it
does seem unlikely plus the next episode
would be a bit weird to have him in the
penthouse and then be like ah you're the
guy running it all you're some other
[ __ ] now the final theory is quite a
wild one and according to the leaks on
the series it will in fact be revealed
that it's actually uncle kevin spoilers
who is your uncle yes yours behind the
whole thing you dumb punk you should
have known it was uncle kevin's spoilers
but look at you now you look stupid
anyway those are the most interesting
theories so far and now i turn the
questions over to you who do you think
ekko's uncle is you better comment below
and let me know and as a thank you just
to make it up to you you'll be entered
into a prize through on the 3rd of
december in which we're giving away 3
copies of the spider-man 4k trilogies
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
forgive me for calling you a sucker so
much and comment below with your
thoughts on the episode we pick the
comments out random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check our
breakdown of episode 3 which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
all the easter eggs in it or the things
you missed and just give our general
theories so it's definitely worth
checking out right after this if not
then thanks for sitting through the
video hope you enjoy the rest of the day
and you take care of yourself i've been
paul you've been the best and i'll see
you on the next one take care peace